Trinity the top ah when I think of drag
queens is a few quickly that are like
the ultimate queens and Trinity the Tuck
is one of them
you are keeping creative during the
self-isolation time you are reimagining
these winners looks and the queens and
fans are loving it tell me about the
idea of doing that you know my partner
now I collaborate on a lot of ideas he
is such a great force behind helping me
with with creative stuff the last few
years and this is just an idea that we
came up together we want to do tributes
to the winners and and put something out
there for the fans the fans love
anything to do if you can anchor it back
to the show and this is just a fun way
for us to check them up with some
content and you know in something
positive another thing that is lifting
people is season 12 of drag race you are
watching I'm launching I want some a
Trinity's teeth who are you rooting for
right now in season 12 well there's the
cast in itself is amazing like literally
are amazing i when i saw the cast I
immediately was drawn to two of the
girls which were Jada and peachy and
that's still the thing it's it's it's
not waivers at the beginning I have a
couple other girls I'm like oh they're
great like jammed it's so good this past
week though you should have won the
challengers book airs sleeping on Jan I
don't know why but it just stopped you
know it's just like the Brady Bunch
again it's not it's not Marsha Marsha
Marsha its gg gg gg Jan you know on the
sidelines tonight you rule the water
you are safe let me join the other girls
I know Jan wanted to witness like God
didn't see her face when she turned
around of course you want all-stars for
relations on that why our fans get in
love celebrity drag race well the number
one thing they're gonna love about
celebrity drag race is that they're
getting to see some of their very
favorite let see be again we're not
necessarily competing I can't say too
much but you get to see a different side
a different dynamic to the girls because
of the circle that were put under and I
had so much fun it was such a good time
they're gonna love happen the
celebrities were fantastic like truly
truly committed and if you love drag
race you're gonna love the leather
drivers yeah I'm I'm really looking
forward to it I can't wait to see which
celebrities are actually gonna be there
because I think it's like there's a lot
of fans of this show so I think there's
gonna be some great select on there
we just recently saw that you got into a
little Twitter back and forth with James
Charles who is very problematic himself
in many ways where does that stand now
because I know you guys tied a Twitter
back and forth was there any reaching
out no not on Twitter or just like
private messaging between you two oh
absolutely not I don't think it was as
big of a deal as people made it out to
be you know I again you can't really
tell context through you know typing
something online my humor is very crass
and sometimes it may be read wrong
so we his initial post was just a dumb
tweet and I made a dumb shady remark and
just in fun and it was fun it was a
remark yeah so and it was like it was
like hearted I think it escalated after
that yeah I probably could have handled
that a lot but lean but you know
again I'm not one of those people that
sugarcoat things I'm not one of those
people it's gonna talk about you behind
your back I just put it all up and you
know I don't wish him any ill will he's
obviously a very successful business
person and good luck to him but you know
it's done what I love is your podcast
you just had a Toronto Queen on one of
my friends Priyanka tell me about the
podcast and why you love doing this
media you know um podcasting was not
something I ever was interested in I
never listened to them and my partner
Leo listens to them all the time and he
got me sent to a couple of podcasts
about different things and some they had
to do some that had to do like murder
mystery because you know that I like
that um I started listening to that I'm
like this is kind of fun so it's just to
have fun and and gossip and like just
like you would your friend then that's
what I have on my clock guys I have my
my drag friends some fun not drag race
but um we just stupid to talk about
gossip and have fun and that's really
good you know this it's all about being
yourself and honest and your opinion
yeah and I love it because I think at
this time specifically it is a dark time
for so many people it's having something
like the podcast to listen to is really
lifting people's spirits off are you
working on new music Akashi
oh my gosh so I just started with a
producer on a new album it's gonna be
featuring past winners of drag race
we're still contemplating on the name it
might be like something like the
winner's circle and then like that where
I just feature different winners
we haven't start production on it
obviously like as soon as Kovac started
it was just like and everything but I
have gotten some of the tracks the
background ground tracks and it's really
excited oh hey there if you want more
LGBTQ news and exclusive interviews
click Subscribe or watch these videos